hé tout le monde
ici, nous sommes sur
papa Afrique du Sud et nous tournons l'
atteinte de l'impossible directement pour 22.
ils ne voulaient pas que l'année se termine sans
vous enlever pour être sorti au
théâtre et merci de soutenir Top
Guns moyen
salut les
enfants Chris  mccorry
merci hé euh écoute nous avons vraiment une
règle nous devons prendre la photo oh ouais
nous filmons tu dois prendre cette photo
hé tu viens pas sur ta vie bonne
chance d'accord on te voit là-bas
oh ouais merci pour le soutien  Jeff
Jordan Maverick, comme toujours, merci de
nous avoir permis de vous divertir, c'est vraiment
l'ordre d'une vie
très chanceuse,
vous passez de très
bonnes vacances en toute sécurité,
nous vous verrons au cinéma
le 22 décembre, le plus grand film de
l'année arrive  sur Paramount plus top
gun Maverick